I saw a few months ago I was watching
two bears one cave with uh I think it
was theovon and Tom sagora and they just
started talking about you in a really
positive way does that feel insane to
see two of the most famous comedians on
the internet at least let alone just in
the comedy World start talking about you
out of the blue both of those guys were
always super nice to me thinking about
it when I left La Theo called me one day
just out of the blue just checking in on
me last night at at the Wilbur I heard
people talking about Burke and I know
that a lot of people they spend a lot of
time with us they spend a lot of time
watching videos and and podcast and
going to shows and you're never really
sure how these people are in real life
and I'm not saying that there aren't
I'm sure that there are some
comedians that that you're watching and
they might be for the 99% of
the ones that I was lucky enough to meet
on the church and and throughout all
this have been very very nice to me very
kind